[Music]
three two one action hey guys welcome
back to off-the-record where we talk
about whatever we want and today we have
Nikki blaze make a radio show host and
the co-host of No Chaser which is Tim's
podcast yeah one of them right within
Ricky you make how long have you done no
chaser since February but first
that's it thank you to our sponsor love
book love book allows you to create a
custom design book for any occasion
telling someone why they are special has
never been this easy and fun you can
customize your book as much or as little
as you like love books help customers
express the sentiments that they may be
difficult to say out loud
ah users can create characters that look
just like themselves and the recipient
down to the outfits and accessories try
a unique gift this year for Christmas
Valentine's Day anniversaries birthdays
or just because for about the cost of
flower delivery you can have a premium
you can have a premium gift that will
last for years not just a few days but
book now offers and membership program
as well you'll receive a free book when
you sign up 50% off any additional books
unlimited free digital books and
discounts on gift wrap and other pro
Dukes visit love book online.com slash
off the record to receive a special 20%
discount only for our listeners again
that's love book online.com slash off
the record to receive a special 20%
discount or just go ahead and click in a
description box below
we got a link right there baby that's
cute
Nikki blades has anyone ever told you
that you have the most American
Gladiators name of all time I do I
thought I got to compete you could I
probably could like [ __ ] nitro you
got Nikki bleed God you remember the
[ __ ]
oh yeah bow why didn't I get comic book
character all the time alright I can see
that
I could see that what does blade stand
for is that my mom she her last name is
blades it's blood
so it's actually my last name oh it's
not even estate no it's actually mean
it's not short for bladder zoella but
I'm not that exotic did you know that
American Gladiators nitro was actually
his last name oxide in his first day of
nitro so Nicki's a stage name that nikki
is the Nikki sissy's name but I never
went by Nikki growing up because my dad
wanted to name me that after that damn
print song oh oh yeah darling Nikki
horse yeah and so my Purple Rain baby
let's go so I never went by I never went
by Nikki until I started doing more work
and then yep I was trying to figure out
what culture that was blades please I
don't know my mom is mainly Filipino so
I don't know love this is maybe Mickey
badass there's a lot of real way to say
it mom it's real exotic right are you
into me I'm curious about that I can't
even get on the purple over alcohol no
no I think it was through no we met
before I did wild and out but I don't
remember exactly how we even got in
cause you knew him before but yeah I
know him before I did Wilin out and then
from wildin out got into Julie in the
podcast and yeah well because I didn't
radio so it was like hey I think we
should get somebody that can actually
speak I think you might be qualified for
the job sweet and you've done that you
said you did no chaser since last
February so how many bottles of Class A
is all is that I can't even remember
they drink what every time damn near
basically yeah I don't remember you guys
drinking when I went on because you
don't drink not fine now the tree no
it's not the same we were talking about
so Rick doesn't drink so for everybody
that doesn't know Rick does not drink
he's never drank in his life that's why
I get along with you you know what I
mean like not recovering or stop or
whatever reason just don't drink he just
never drank so when Tim and I are late
we have another guest who doesn't drink
are we gonna be alcoholics in this
episode no we'll just sit there and try
not to get drunk I look like it in this
one because mine's hiding I'm drinking
with her - maybe this is Rosie doesn't
really drink that much what about
drinking helps the podcast out um I
don't necessarily think it helps out but
we just like alcohol and we like alcohol
and I mean it makes you feel good helps
you connect better or it makes me not
think about what I'm saying and
everybody just kind of feel more relaxed
yeah I mean Tim literally shot how many
episodes of while and out holding a damn
bottle of Hennessy so you know it kind
of if you know you know what they should
do a acid podcast cuz you go deep in
that [ __ ] brain with that I
don't know if it'd be interesting to
listen to though right
that just but what if you have to do
acid to understand it so everyone that's
listening to the podcast
everyone's on acid and they get it but
the only way to get it is to be on it so
is that your future podcast cuz I cannot
do that no I don't want anything and you
don't like hallucinogenic drugs no that
kind of reminds me I remember as a kid
they had this TV show and Nickelodeon
weird like if you because they were like
promoting this show I forgot what it was
but pretty much if you wrote in ahead of
time before the show premiered then
they'll send you a scratch-and-sniff so
you can be watching the show and you can
like scratch dicks smells dicks tickly
you remember a little popsicle I do I
recall I remember he was very sassy
that's dick Stickley he would go yeah I
think it was oh and you like scratch
like write to me
stick stick me maybe maybe these young
people over here didn't I reminds me of
that where it's like a stay out of that
listening to the podcast or watching
this show then write to us and we'll or
email us and we'll send you some acid
and you can enjoy it
very good like STONER cast right so then
like you get a delivery of weave so you
got a smoke right before you listen to
the episode Oh
or we can do drinking games to people
barely drinking games with our videos
don't be like yeah like if they say this
word how many times you got if I can
take a shot or whatever well like every
time do some talk about beating
someone's ass yeah take a shot
I feel good people died love your people
first from alcoholism yeah poisoning but
the acid I'm gonna pass on okay yeah
have you have you tried no no no like I
am scared of like liking it
no I'm scared of whatever there's some
[ __ ] in here that I don't want to deal
with you know and that makes you and it
forces you that's why a lot of people
micro those boring to live in the
natural world that's why I drink alcohol
so I don't have [ __ ] sponsored by [ __ ]
I think we're trying to make it
sponsored by alcohol but he's really
Georgian the ass this is legal
stop going the route that we can get so
it's illegal okay I forgot what you say
there are things like deeper things
swirling that you don't wanna deal with
do you play it's like we're gonna go do
you plan on addressing them at some
point in the future course okay yeah
when do you do therapy uh you know no I
go and I talk every morning it is kind
of like therapy
this is gin tonic therapy you know um on
Sundays okay what's your do what's your
drink of choice with Nemo says oh no I
can't let most Oh dashes my stomach ends
up messed up on mimosa oh sweet I'm
tequila right now yeah what's your
tequila
yeah class Arizona we're not sponsored
by them so I'm a down-home yoga what Don
Julio what the different flavors Blanco
Blanco oh my why is that way to me cuz
it's Blanco it's white his lily-white
that's why they made that for the white
people's no I know but I thought it was
like the Mexicans are haha like these
are for white people
no no Reposado love rubber top mm-hmm
and then there's and yell I work in
nightlife since I was 21
alcohol company what do you think about
all the celebrity alcohol companies
Eddie the rocks coming out with tequila
and like I don't know some fools like
Ryan Reynolds house
connor class a casa amigos is amigos cos
amigos is north morning there we go
George Clooney are they good costume
eNOS is good oh yeah I mean right it's
art I'm not a lot not a big fan of it
I'm not a fan of patron and all either
so I mean for the price point it's not
bad at all yeah true $30 sure yeah I
mean I work with in Hazzard Bush at like
21 I was a blood like girl oh wow so you
doesn't track I've had to go to bars
like in the marina and whenever you see
the girls that are like do you want to
try a sample of Jameson those you oh
yeah I was hurt so you have to learn a
lot about what makes the tequila good
because to someone who doesn't drink it
all just tastes like burn I think you
have to find what alcohol you kind of
like that you don't feel disgusted by
yeah then you figure it out through
there like what are there like notes
through this okay so like okay so like
class asel will use that so it's um
sweeter yeah it's a dessert it's a
dessert to give a vision it has like a
vanilla aftertaste so it's a lot easier
to drink it doesn't burn versus like a
patron which tastes like gasoline some
yeah um yeah it's rough but there's like
levels to it and how many times it's
distilled your tequila should be smooth
as [ __ ] so the smoother it is usually
the more expensive yeah yeah you want
depends but yeah here's what amazing
thing is one of the smoothest things
I've ever drink its water that's free
why doesn't you [ __ ] up are you even
listening have you drink a gallon ah
[ __ ] mustard you like every five minutes
you ever thrown up from drinking too
much water I had
go die from drinking too much water so
you know so it [ __ ] you up pretty bad
no it doesn't yeah well I definitely
[ __ ] you up it definitely bad way
nothing good way do you smoke don't do
anything nothing I mean God
have you ever cold-brew BAM but have you
ever oh I forget [ __ ] up like Joe in
high school I used to try to fry my
brains out I don't even know I don't
want to know where I'm waking up in
three days why don't I don't see my
parents for like a week you're like the
bender type of person yeah I'm like in
random strangers houses Oh new friends
new names inside cars on a freeway going
to Arizona I like that kind of stuff you
probably saw that leftover alcohol in
your system that's why you can you know
what when I drink alcohol I do feel like
the ecstasy getting activated sometimes
yeah I don't know if it feels crazy no
I'm like I could relate to that but not
that I feel it every time but I could
relate to that feeling of like your body
remembers you start feeling like those
picking your brain and like the little
body hi are you once belt yeah yeah yeah
I'll drink it all nice I'm like have you
ever go for kind of a massage right now
why were you guys randomly going Arizona
um
I think also we were helping my friends
older brothers smuggle ecstasy into
another state there was a big rave going
on no serious limitation yeah yeah yeah
so we were helping him so we were like
so he rented this van and then we were
like taking the the covers off and
taking the cushions out of the van and
we're packing with boats and boats of
ecstasy all over boats is about a
thousand pills yeah both both of us they
were about you mean like a boatload
Arizona Kathy nocturnal was there at
that one time and then I remember I
forgot what happened but we got pretty
[ __ ] up so yeah I wonder why
I love how you guys are traveling and
smuggling but still getting [ __ ] up
which increases the chance of getting
pulled over and caught well cuz we're
the kids yeah I know
so like the older guys know that so the
older guys there applies I don't know
early 20 25 were like 15 oh so they're
giving us kid I mean that the pills so
we can have fun on our own but I do
remember on the way back I think there's
only one road back into California and
that's when the whole freeway shut down
for like eight hours and it was just a
freeway full of ravers everyone sigh
[ __ ] it and I know it's almost like an
after party people sort of bump in music
and then we would start visiting people
and random people's cars and so we open
both sides of our van and people come
and hang on in hours in traffic Wow cuz
the freeway was locked down we weren't
going anywhere everyone just turned
their car off fun tailgating at 15 late
- your smuggling story though because
when I was about 15 I smuggled a
hedgehog into California for my sister
for her birthday so we went is over all
we drove to Las Vegas
we got the Hedgehog and then we packed
it in a bunch of we just put it in like
a little cage and then we put a bunch of
blankets over it when we were at customs
you guys knew you're smuggling
absolutely do they make sounds smuggle
no dog you know who has to worry about
barking or nice to smuggle [ __ ]
parrots like exotic parrots from TJ here
and then he said he would like get them
drunk a little bit oh yeah it's a kind
of getting buzzed so that they're not
did you think that a drunk pair it would
be kind of more annoying like drunk
dudes and drunk chicks it's so [ __ ]
annoying when you're not drunk
oh they are totally sent so many
messages I shouldn't have sent I'm to
stay away from alcohol listen yeah how
did you get into radio I got asked - oh
you got it buddy I got invited how are
you not well you're nervous cuz I feel
like that's a big thing you know I do I
go
the air and then just if someone just
like if I never was into entertainment
sometimes what you want to be on the
radio I apply say no oh why I had done
some other work before TV I worked with
Maxim I did I've been modeling for a
while so kind of like the on-camera
stuff and doing that was fine when I got
asked to do radio
I would been doing remember when
snapchat takeovers were really a big
thing and people used to go oh yeah so I
was doing a lot for arsenic TV you know
the girls under swimsuits all the time
mm-hmm so I saw them but I didn't see
the branding totally so I was doing a
lot of the snapchat takeovers and I had
done an interview at that
amantha station that I work at Kay win
in Stockton when I was running for the
maximum hometown hottie contest and so
since I had did that they kind of
already knew who I was and then they
were looking for somebody to come in
they asked me initially it was like yo
this is backwards I wanted to do TV do
like I'm hometown hottie [ __ ] I'm never
doing this no this is many of years
after to where I was like well this you
ain't done a job in a while so you might
want to start planning on being able to
do other things as if this goes away you
need to start using your other skills so
that's thinking ahead though I had to
because realistically if you're modeling
or you're doing any type of
entertainment work you got to figure out
how are you gonna continue this job who
would have thought husband better [ __ ]
find a rich [ __ ] right now he
still is he's looking for research I'm
looking for rich [ __ ] husband's
against Alicia yeah oh yeah I think you
would think so until you actually like
talk to people that are in marriages
they don't want to be in and they are
miserable like cuz they're not with a
billionaire you had the B to it you're
like no I could put up with them that's
what I'm saying yeah I'm like a
billionaire and then we were out one of
his [ __ ] restaurants and yet merch
there and he was picking out shirts for
me he's like hey you should get that one
and I'm all like looks like [ __ ] not
this is dope oh I love this [ __ ]
it's like I could be a good ho okay does
this make you happy I love you hundred
dollar bills you gave me a couple shirts
I'm saying stipend huh no I got I got
what RIT what kind of
it was cool t-shirts that were branded
and I just don't want to say the name of
the cafe it's a it's a rock cafe but no
mmm heavy metal cafe shirts I just want
to be like how expensive where that's
not expensive
that's like $30 so I'm like were you
going where you like now at a really
example you said twice but add some
zeros to that if you're gonna be a hot
what that's what I'm saying a lot it
doesn't take me much to be happy he said
that yeah but okay I gave it was Nord
servers on to be a little better the
point is I mean even then you're even
then you're pushing it I'm like come on
how much [ __ ] do I have to put up with
right if I can buy it myself and I'm not
putting up with you but he's a
billionaire so you know how many
t-shirts that it unlimited lifetime
t-shirts so much my theory with the
whole marrying for money thing is that
it's still not your money until you have
that whole thing so you eventually to
get the money you gotta get to pass so
you're smart so if you gonna make it so
you don't get the money you don't get
the money to your divorce
so why married reminder that credit card
with your name on it you are you smart
enough to ask for it what your name on
it
yeah allowance see men your sugar maybe
why you got to get made for because
after they die which I'll kill them
willing to kill that's you know so your
we can find you one please
I don't even care about looks Wow [ __ ]
I care about bank account see that opens
up oh okay I'd make a really good girl a
really good hot and right with
technology yeah mmm-hmm damnit I never
even thought of that [ __ ] and you can
transition back to if you need young cuz
I always say if I ever go to jail I'm
gonna be the biggest gangsters side
[ __ ] oh you're holding the pocket I'm
gonna be the [ __ ] Queen oh you're
holding the bucket everywhere they gonna
be walking around dragging I should say
like that's right he's [ __ ]
protecting me [ __ ] yeah we
this [ __ ] be biting the pot yep
wait so if you if you commit a crime do
you go to the jail that's the gender of
the time that you commit the crime Oh
what do you commit like I steal the car
yeah well as a male Chelsea Manning and
then I quickly go do I go to girl jail
now no I don't I think they've actually
been trying to figure that out because I
mean it's like the same thing with the
bathrooms right you're how are you
that's true there's a couple cases of
guys who had gender reassignment and
then they go female prisons because that
would be dangerous for them well it's
better especially if they a pool of
piranhas well especially if you
committed like a sex assault crime and
then you get gender reassignment and
then you go no female present like
that's got to be kind of [ __ ] crazy
yeah I wonder if there's any cases of
that of somebody actually trying to do
that so they can avoid going too that's
what I would do do a couple extra
chicken ball you would people don't want
to go to jail we know that immediately
if I'm going to live I'm gonna practice
how to suck dick wait but if they're in
prison
who's paying for their gender
reassignment stuff gotta read before so
I still like a Mercedes or some so
you're plotting it so you're plotting
I'm gonna commit this crime then I'm
going to do this so you already want to
go to jail that's my destination why
would you want to I just have a couple
lay overs in between guys everything in
life
[Music]
[Music]